what's up elimination today I'm going to
talk about the seven lifestyle changes
that you need to adopt to be a success
and as always guys if you hear a point
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired as well and also writing it
down helps you lock it in for yourself
to enjoy so Arthur gasping entrepreneurs
what are the habits that you need to
have to be a success what do you see as
in morning routines and what do you see
the lifestyle changes that people make
to go from having a job to becoming a
successful entrepreneur and taking an
idea that you have and making something
amazing what are the changes that you
need to make in your life to be able to
get there and so today I'm going to
share with you my seven lifestyle
changes I think every entrepreneur needs
to make to become a success
[Music]
number one is established a morning
routine for success I think this is so
critical so important most people wake
up and their life just explodes on them
they have a morning routine but it
wasn't designed with purpose
you know it's wake up to go to the
washroom grab a cup of coffee breakfast
and rush out you know it's not designed
with intent and with purpose I think
what happens far too often is
entrepreneurs get inspired by something
I've random point in time and then they
have these moments of boldness where
they go and want to create something
amazing and then they wake up the next
day and it's over they're back to their
baseline again they fall back down to
earth to think about all those limiting
personal beliefs and they say that big
bold idea that you that I had yesterday
that I can't do that that's too crazy as
to what was I thinking that was really
stupid like Who am I to do that you
falling back down you live in a limited
life all over again and that happens to
every single day and so whatever that
thing was that got you inspired
motivated thinking big resourceful
unstoppable instead of it happening
randomly once a week or once a month or
whatever happens schedule it in with
intent with purpose put it into your
morning routine so every day you start
with that thing that gets you feeling
big bold brave and unstoppable put that
into your morning routine and then let
it carry forward for you
today lifestyle change number two is
create a better environment the
environment that you're in matters the
people that you're around matters it's
the physical environment that you're in
matters with the sounds that are
happening matter and so when you are
working or when you're in work mode what
are you listening to what's on what what
sounds are coming out what's on your
walls around you or your an environment
that makes you come alive that makes you
want to think bigger when I'm at my
office I have these posters on the wall
of people who inspire me for different
reasons five different people who
inspire me for different messages and
different reasons I walk into there like
this is it I got to do something big
today right and those five people may
mean nothing to you that's okay it means
something to me
it helps me believe more and so creating
that physical environment for yourself
you know a lot of people will say well I
don't have the money to have a private
island because the tide line is going to
be the thing that makes me come alive
right you can have a picture of a
program you can get the feeling of a
private island you know it doesn't have
to cost a lot of money to create an
amazing environment for yourself
think about the friends that you're
hanging around with thinking about the
videos that you watch and the things
that you consume right are you are you
going on YouTube and watching prank
videos or you're going on YouTube and
watching videos like this where you get
to be motivated and inspired and learn
something
having that built in so you have a great
environment that sets you up for success
and reinforces to success all the time
it's hardly an entrepreneur because we
don't have a boss there's nobody saying
why are you on Facebook right now right
there's nobody saying why are you
wearing stirring those snaps and on
Instagram and just texting people why
are you not working right that's what a
boss would do we our own boss and this
is a great freedom in that right there's
an amazing freedom but part of the
reason why maybe you want to start your
own business but there's also a lack of
accountability and so you want to have
an environment to hold you temple when
I'm working and then I look up and I see
Steve Jobs looking back at me like get
back to working keep working hustle also
harder go when I'm watching the videos
and doing the research for the videos in
this channel it reinforces it like all
these successful people are telling me
every day you got to work harder you got
to push better you got to learn more you
got to you know it just inspires me to
want to keep doing my absolute best and
they hold me accountable my environment
holds me accountable because I don't
have a boss in my business so you need
to create an environment that is
designed for your success lifestyle
change number three to adopt is you need
to accept responsibility stop
complaining and start accepting
responsibility a lot of people use
excuses for why their business is not
successful right the economy is in the
tank we have a new president interest
rates are up or interest rates are down
or there's a war whatever there's always
an excuse there's always a reason why
and as long as you can blame somebody
else and you are never going to do
anything as long as you could put the
blame over here it's the president's
fault that I'm not more successful it
means you don't have to do anything
because you give up the responsibility
right it's their fault successful
entrepreneurs successful people accept
the responsibility you lost a customer
it's your fault if you're not more
successful it's your fault always accept
responsibility in every situation your
relationship isn't where you want to go
it's not your partner's flaws your fault
fix it now sure are other people
involved yes but blaming them doesn't
fix anything so accepting responsibility
in every situation understanding how do
I fix this what can I do because I can't
control everything else I'm not
controlling interest rates I'm not
controlling the economy I can show what
I do every day so let's fix that if
you're not where you want to be it's
your fault accept that and start making
some changes it sucks because it's
depressing because so easy to have
somebody to blame but it's also
empowering because you know that if you
start making some changes you can start
seeing big things happen for you a lot
of the best opportunities come from
complaints where other people are
complaining that something is a certain
way successful entrepreneurs turn that
into an opportunity the fact that people
are complaining means there's a pain
take that pain and solve it there's a
business for you and that's what
successful people do they don't complain
they don't whine they don't just talk to
their friends and say how bad everything
is the accept responsibility they take
action and they turn those pain points
into opportunities
[Music]
lifestyle change number four is you need
to take action take action successful
people take action too many people just
want to be a success they get off just
thinking about ideas right here's
another idea and it will be great if you
can do this okay here's what I would do
if I only McDonald that's great but
nothing's ever going to happen for you
until you take actions thinking alone is
not enough
taking alone is only part of the
equation you got to do something about
it
and what happens a lot is you get an
idea this happens a lot of people get
some idea and you have your job but you
don't do anything about that idea just
have some job you keep going on because
you say all these reasons why you can't
do this business and so you're working
on this job and then somebody else goes
off and makes millions of dollars and
has a huge impact on the world off of
that idea see that was my idea
that wasn't that was their idea too the
only difference is they did something
about it so don't be upset at them be
upsetting yourself is nobody's fault
takes responsibility nobody else's fault
but your own you have to do something
having the idea is not enough have a big
vision it's amazing it's great I want
you have that big vision take an action
step small think big act small
consistently every day
go do something successful people take
action and so the next time you get an
idea just find some small way to start
test it out you may think hey it could
be on a lifestyle thank you like you
said hey I want to take salsa class
instead of dreaming four years will take
you salsa classes go out and take a
salsa class you may hate it I don't
think I'll hate it if you take it at
Chinatown salsa but you may hate it and
at least now you know you can spend the
rest of your life wondering and worrying
about it or you may take it and love it
and then you adjust and find other ways
to get involved in it and continue
dancing maybe becomes a business for you
when you get an idea about something
find a small way to get started
immediately stop waiting stop the lane
take
[Music]
you know you can't do everything
yourself in your business and you're
likely doing things that you shouldn't
be doing if you're doing something
important you have to build a team the
first person I hired was the one hour
day and he freed up more than an hour of
my time of day because he was better at
the work than I was and then I slowly
built up my team and so you can hire
somebody may not have enough money to
have somebody come on full-time in your
business but to hire somebody for an
hour a day or a couple hours a week
helps take off some of the tasks you
shouldn't be doing will really help you
want to spend as much time in the CEO
role as possible that's where you want
to be and so looking at your schedule
I've seen where am i spending time that
should be eliminated what things can be
automated and then whatever is left it
still has to get done how do i delegate
some of these other things so that I can
focus on what I'm great at so when I
started my youtube channel I did
everything myself I'm a big advocate of
not spending money to making money don't
go inside hiring somebody for making
zero in the business but as soon as I
started making money on my youtube
channel you know doing everything I was
the cameraman I was the editor was the
researcher I was in front of the camera
everything I students started making on
YouTube channel I poured a back in and
the first person I hired was an editor
because editing took me a long time I
wasn't very good at it I didn't want to
get good at it more importantly and then
as I started making more I hired more
people more editors the cameraman I
bought more gear I got you know I got
cameras I got microphones you know I got
researcher they got people to help me on
the YouTube channel with the comments
and so my team grew as my business grew
but the thing that really helps
skyrocket the early growth was getting
my first editor so as soon as you can
afford it bringing somebody on to help
alleviate some of the tasks you're not
good at and more importantly don't want
to get good at either can really help
you quickly scale up your business and
reduce the stress because you get most
stressed out when you're doing work you
don't want to do the number-6 lifestyle
change you need to make to be successful
is you need to be consistent so many
people are not consistent so many
entrepreneurs I talked to have a day
where they're on fire and doing so much
work and building up and sending emails
and marketing and pouring their love
into part development and then
nothing the next day nothing and next
thing nothing and it just falls apart
until like next week or next month
another great day see we're productive
you have to understand it takes time for
momentum to build you will not have
success but just having these short
spurts with long gaps in between it's
far better to spend half an hour to an
hour every single day on your business
then one day a week all in on the
company because momentum takes time to
build up and if you look at anybody
who's at success in any field that's
just entrepreneurship in any field it's
not just working it's not just taking
action it's taking action consistently
every single day put it in your calendar
and sticking by the calendar doing the
work consistently is what separates the
high achievers from everybody else and
there's always an excuse why you can't
do it right I get it is always some kind
of excuse there's a wedding to go to
there's an illness in the family you
know there's legit reasons and there's
others that are not legit that are just
you know they stop in your fear you can
always find a reason why you shouldn't
do something always and if you look at
the most successful people in the world
they had more reasons than you do for
not doing anything look at how they
start look at where they came from most
of these people I'm not talking about
inherited wealth I talk of people who
built something for themselves look at
where they came from they had less than
what you already have right now they had
every excuse in the world not to take
action consistently every reason in the
world why they had to go off and do
something else instead and they found
the time somehow to focus on building
the thing that they said it was
important to them and they did it
meanwhile you're sitting on your excuses
and your reasons for why you can't do it
stop the excuses consistent daily
massive action and habit number seven is
you have to believe in yourself I think
of all of the ones we've talked about
today none of the matter if you don't
believe in yourself you could take lots
of action but if you don't believe in
the work that you're doing I believe
that you can make it happen it's not
going to happen what you believe you can
do you will
if you believe that you can you can if
you believe that you can't then you
can't and so I think one of the most
important things that you can do is
learn how to develop that inner belief
in yourself I got it a lot to my parents
who told me I was Evan Chris truly
Carmichael could do anything that I
wanted I continued a tradition off to my
son where every time I drop them up at
school or say good night it's either
chemicals can do anything or I'm hating
chemicals and I can do anything to give
him the confidence in himself but if you
don't get that from your parents you
don't get that from your friends it's
fine get that from the videos get that
from books get that from resources get
them from circles around you I got more
of my confidence now on going through
the videos that I put up I'm surrounded
by successful people daily not in person
but through my videos every day I was
trying to bite you on musk and Steve
Jobs and Howard Schultz and all these
people feeding knowledge and wisdom and
motivation into me making me a better
leader making me more confident making
me believe in what I'm doing in myself
more if you want to change the world you
have to believe that you can change the
world you can say it all you want but if
you don't believe it nothing's going to
happen and so building that
self-confidence up creating that
environment and that morning routine and
those rituals or if you find the things
if this channel makes you believe in
yourself more than watch the channel
more if my channel doesn't do that
unsubscribe go somewhere else but do
something because that inner belief is
critical successful people believe in
themselves
successful people believe in the vision
that they have where nobody else
believes in it they have this big vision
for what they want to accomplish
everybody thinks they're crazy it
doesn't matter I'm still going to go out
and do it you need to have that
unshakable belief in yourself in the
project in the mission if you want to go
out and make something big so that's my
take on the seven lifestyle changes that
you need to make in order to be a
success I'd love to know what did you
guys think which one was your favorite
and why did I miss an eight nine ten
that you guys want to add to the list
put it down in the comments below super
curious to hear what you have to say I
also want to give a big shout out to
Katie Cruz Katie thank you so much
you're picking up a copy of my book
you're one word and for making that
awesome video on it as well I really
really really appreciate the support and
I'm soaked
that you enjoyed the book so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much loved I'll see you soon